so last year for the first time in the
history of my channel when I did my
extended video on the editing and
Suicide Squad I indulged in the
well-worn trope where a reviewer plays
up needing drugs or alcohol to get
through the process now in the script it
was supposed to be cooking oil as a like
total subversion of the trope but at the
last minute I decided to just use an old
cough syrup bottle instead so I wound up
inadvertently just recreating the trope
in its entirety in an attempt at being
witty anyway let's talk about the art of
storytelling in the book of Henri
[Music]
I'm gonna warn you the book of Henry is
an infectious movie there's a decent
risk that knowing about this movie will
make you insufferable to your friends
and family as you insist on recounting
every mind-numbing twist in excruciating
detail the book of Henry is a case study
in what happens when you spend 20 years
writing and rewriting the same script
crime novelist Steven Horowitz
originally started shopping the script
around in the mid 90s it got some buzz
and made the rounds but ultimately
wasn't produced Horowitz held on to it
and kept making changes as the years
passed and he grew older I wrote the
first draft of this 18 years ago so it's
almost like I grew up with this story in
my head the weird way it has all my
enthusiasm and energy of youth and then
along the years I've rewritten it so
things that I've learned along the way
I've been able to bring to it it's no
wonder then that the film is something
of a cross-section of two decades of
cloying children's films and films about
children from little man Tate and Radio
Flyer through pay it forwards to
Extremely Loud and Incredibly Close
the end product is from a critical
perspective like a Sudoku puzzle the
failings and poor decisions are
interlinked in a way that explaining one
requires understanding the relative
construction of the others there is not
a singular problem but a complex system
of codependent problems that are
ultimately rooted in the insurmountable
flaw that is the movies basic premise
this is a movie about a mother Susan who
sets out to murder her neighbor Glenn
and kidnap his stepdaughter Christina
following instructions left behind by
her genius son Henry who just died of
brain cancer or it's about Henry a kid
genius who decides to kill his neighbor
Glenn
but develops terminal brain cancer and
spends his final days preparing
meticulous instructions so his mother
Susan can carry out the murder and
kidnapping after his death but it's also
a heartwarming life-affirming reminder
that cynicism weighs us down and we
should be doers not dreamers and we
should murder our neighbors but only if
their kids are sad because as we all
know a sad teenager
is an abused teenager so to start this
off properly I'm going to try as best I
can to simply factually recount the plot
of the film without commentary questions
or asides alright let's go Henry and his
younger brother Peter get on the bus
while Henry in voiceover wax is
philosophical about the nature of man
suggesting that sometimes people will
surprise you while the rest of the time
people are exactly who they seem to be
which is to say cruel in class Henry
improvises his essay project in front of
the class mocks and other students and
tells his teacher that he shouldn't be
in an advanced class because house is
better for life psychosocial development
I need to interact with a peer group at
enormous growing time while waiting
after school Henry buys and sells stocks
over the payphone until mom Susan pulls
up in a beat-up car Henry tells her she
should buy a new car because they can
afford a new car but mom says at home
Peter bugs Henry over the radio until
Henry agrees to let Peter helped him
with his Rube Goldberg machine it's all
about timing setup covering every
contingency that night Susan puts Peter
into the bath and then plays video games
while Henry does the family finances
telling mom that she needs to pay more
attention at bedtime
Susan reads the two boys a story that
she wrote she finds an engineering award
that Henry won and Henry gives the medal
to Peter at breakfast the next morning
Henry continues to bug mom about the
finances trying to teach her how to use
the computer and the kids correct her
middle finger posture when she flips
Henry off they're called outside by
their neighbor Glenn's sickle man the
police commissioner who complains about
the leaves on their lawn and Susan dotes
on the neighbor girl Cristina at work
Susan banters with her co-worker Sheila
her boss a John gives her her paycheck
suggests that she sets up direct deposit
and Susan says she'll need to check with
Henry you have to ask your
eleven-year-old he's almost 12 at school
Henry asked Kristina how she's doing and
Peter gets beat up the metal that Henry
gave Peter gets broken back home Peter
sulks Henry cheers him up by doing this
then Susan comes home with Sheila and
the two get drunk Henry wakes up with a
headache spies on Christine the
next-door and ominous music tells us
thing is up with Glenn the next morning
Susan drives the kids in Christina to
school Henry keeps looking at her on the
ride to school and in class and then he
gets up storms in to the principal's
office and says how much longer does
this have to go on they argue about
Christina being abused by Glenn goddamn
it Janis tells him she needs conclusive
evidence and Henry says he'll handle it
alone the kids get picked up by Susan
after school and they stop by Sheila's
then they get groceries and see a dude
beating on his girlfriend Henry wants to
get involved but Susan tells him to mind
his own business back home Henry calls
Child Protective Services on Glenn then
while everyone is unpacking groceries
Christina puts a lot of weighty emphasis
on the fact that Glenn is her Susan
agrees to drive Christina to and from
the upcoming talent show because Glenn
isn't planning on going Susan tells
Henry to be less serious Henry says that
he should have gotten involved in the
supermarket and that violence isn't the
worst thing CPS checks on Glenn and
Christina but the head of CPS twist is
Glenn's brother so Henry starts driving
around town on his bike making notes in
a red notebook buy his books on crime
scene investigation and scouts out a gun
store where he overhears some dude
trying to buy an illegal gun by dropping
the name Dominic
back home Susan is playing Gears of War
and Henry tells her to shut it off at
bedtime there's an argument about who's
on shilada number one and who is on
shilada number two then Susan sings them
a song in the middle of the night Susan
is woken up by Peter screaming because
Henry is having a seizure he's rushed to
hospital it's incurable brain cancer and
Henry explains his own disease to the
neurosurgeon it's gonna be a high-grade
ependymal our Glee apostille Sheila
visits Henry in the hospital and kisses
him Henry and Susan argue about the
finances Henry tells Peter to make mom
read his red notebook after he's gone
Henry and Susan argue about the finances
again then Henry dies in the middle of
the night a few days later Peter comes
home Susan is making brownies for dinner
and dr. hottie comes by for a house call
where he gives Peter his cell number at
work Susan
losing her mind John sends her home but
first tells her that Henry told him via
letter that she has six hundred and
eighty thousand dollars in a checking
account and even more in stocks and
bonds at home Peter finds Henry's red
notebook which mr. sickle met Susan
argues with the book called CPS herself
spies on Glenn and then is told by the
book to check the safe where she finds
tapes and a Walkman the tapes walk her
step-by-step through withdrawing money
from the bank avoiding security cameras
at the gun store and buying I need a
nemesis vanquish 762 with a Linton
ranger night-vision scope a suppressor
and three extra 10-round detachable mags
let's see what dominic has to say about
that huh Susan then gets a copy of
Glenn's signature which she uses as per
the tapes instructions to forge custody
papers for Christina at the talent show
dr. hottie shows up because Peter
invited him once the show starts Susan
synchronizes her watch jumps into her
new car that Henry bought drives back to
the tree fort and sets up to take the
shots while she's aiming back at the
talent show Christina dances a sad dance
and god dammit Janice seeing the sad
dance goes and makes a phone call back
of the tree house Susan has a brief
moment where she realizes that holy crap
she's taking instructions from a tape
recorded by her dead eleven-year-old and
decides not to shoot the police
commissioner in the head with a sniper
rifle standing ovations there's your big
Kuleshov effect a moment for the movie
by the way
Glenn confronts her the hell is going on
here she threatens him jumps in her car
to get back to the talent show Glenn
goes home makes a phone call and shoots
himself in the head Susan gets back just
in time for Peters magic act where he
summons the spirit of Henry from his
trunk in the form of a fake snow storm
Christina
learns her stepfather is dead the court
gives custody to Susan based off of her
falsified documents
Susan burns all evidence of her crimes
and then the movie ends with Susan
tucking on shilada number one and
butterfly number one into bed credits
roll
unless you said the benefit of being
born into a more market this might seem
like an odd point to start the actual
autopsy with but let's talk about the
money issues in the film in the middle
of the movie after Henry dies Susan's
boss John gives her an envelope a letter
from Henry that says she has six hundred
and eighty thousand dollars in the bank
and even more in stocks and bonds
they're rich Henry has from beyond the
grave saved the family from poverty
no more will mom be forced to miss
bedtime because she's working late she
can now realize her true passion to be a
children's picture book author this is a
genre touchstone these sorts of movies
about exceptional kids almost always
have some element of overcoming or just
dealing with financial difficulty often
poverty little man Tate Radio Flyer and
pay it forward all hit this beat in one
way or another single mom raising one or
two kids at the edge of financial ruin
working at a diner driving a beat-up car
joking with her co-workers about the
hardships of being rich here's the
problem the family in the book of Henry
is doing fine they're fine they're fine
they're fine they're fine
earlier in the film John explicitly
points out that they live in a nice
neighborhood
nice neighborhood you live in figured
you for an apartment somewhere I mean
heck they live right next door to the
police commissioner
Henry buys and sells stocks over the
phone Susan only seems to work part-time
and it's never a worry about how they'll
pay the bills Henry has brain surgery
and no one is concerned with how they're
going to pay for it he'll our first
introduction to Susan is contextualized
by money really what's she getting a car
I like you can't write a bernini that
isn't the point
besides these beats come up several
times where Henry explicitly points out
that they can afford stuff and she never
disagrees in fact the opposite she
chides him and says that being able to
afford it isn't the point Bernie that
isn't the point he also tells Susan that
she can afford to quit her job at the
diner and focus on writing
he's constantly telling her to pay
attention to the financial statements
and investment reports and bank
statements but the reveal that they have
all this money doesn't really mean
anything from a story standpoint this
scene at the diner works just as well if
that line is cut because the actually
important line is this what I'm fine
fine
hell if anything the scene accidentally
implies that she was pretending to be in
a paycheque to paycheque situation and
that Henry has outed her wealth to her
friends and co-workers humiliating her
now
the fact that the family isn't living in
poverty isn't itself a problem just
because it's a staple of the genre
doesn't make it mandatory we don't need
that for it to be effective or complete
but as you can see from all these
examples the issue of money comes up
often and explicitly it's not an
unstated dimension or just a background
detail the weird thing is that it
actively works against the theme of the
film now this is a rare film that opens
with a thesis statement
Henry's improvised essay in front of the
class is a direct philosophical
statement aimed at the audience and in
Henry's little Tyler Durden jr. screed
he explicitly denounces the exact sort
of obsession over money that he then
spends the rest of his life pursuing our
legacy isn't what we write on a resume
how many commas we have in our bank
account 70 and you know what give me ten
lifts con with the lemonade chew in the
corner unless you say the benefit of
being born into a bull market
I really wish you'd get a new car I like
you can't afford attorney that isn't the
point
did our financial statement come in the
mail today really read it know what it
says well I told you you don't have to
work any more show me did you bring in
the financial files oh don't you worry I
found the second file drawer in my
captain that I also need to get a hold
of the retirement statement let's talk
about it next week if left comments
above 200 dump it you need to buy a new
car ready there's nothing wrong with
that wall car put you in some long-term
bonds triple tax-free so you have like
680 K and a checking account even more
in stocks and bonds hahaha it's a bad
movie it's all about timing setup
covering every contingency Henry's plan
is bad and stupid it's exactly the kind
of bad and stupid Rube Goldberg Looney
Tunes assassination plan that you'd
expect to be cooked up by a dumb 11 year
old now that in and of itself could be
something fun and interesting if it
weren't offensively paired with the
incredibly heavy subject of rescuing
someone from being raped and the fact
that an adult follows the plan almost to
its completion before having a minor
Epiphany that may be murder isn't
actually the answer this is all
paralleled by constant assertions that
Henry is in fact a super mega genius who
thinks of everything
so for fun let's point out all the flaws
in this flawless plan from the start I
need to emphasize that this is a plan to
kill blend it's also theoretically a
plan to rescue Christina from abuse but
first and foremost it's a plan to kill
Glenn we'll talk about this in more
detail later but so little of the plan
revolves around or involves Christina
that really rescuing Christina is just
the justification for a plot to kill
Glenn you could swap the motive for
anything else and very very little would
change the first thing to highlight is
that most of this plan is drafted before
Henry knows he's going to die
meaning that he was in concept at least
intending to somehow follow through with
these steps this is a big screenwriting
problem
because the writer already knows Henry
dies before the character knows so the
plan is accidentally built around the
convenience that Henry doesn't need to
execute the plan now a lot of the
smaller details of the plan are
suggested as part of arias preparation
montages and illustrations from Henry's
notebook which we fortunately get in
close-ups during the opening credits now
despite all the attention given to my
new details like the type of bullet used
in clearing all the branches the basic
concept of the plan is really simple get
a gun Lord Glenn out into the woods and
shoot him in the head from the comfort
of the Playhouse after that as per the
illustration the body falls into the
river and then the gun gets thrown off
the bridge into the lake the biggest
hole here is that every version of the
plan revolves around shooting Glenn
Henry explicitly scopes out the gun
store and gets the name Dominique at a
point when he just assumes the headaches
are stress except if we take the cancer
out of the equation this is where the
plan ends because even with the whole
Dominic thing even the gun store owner
willing to bend the paperwork rules for
cash isn't going to sell a sniper rifle
to an 11 year old the next biggest hole
is the body again the scriptwriter knows
that neither Henry nor Susan will
actually kill Glenn so they don't bother
to sweat the details which leaves us was
Henry intending for Glenn's body to fall
into the river and by River
I mean Creek this Creek now to me
someone who watches way too many police
procedurals this isn't so much a hide a
body creak as much as it's a hey boss we
found a body down by the creek Creek so
Henry's master plan to kill Glenn is
really just kill him in your own
backyard and hope no one suspects his
neighbors once we move away from the
concept into the weeds of the details is
when the plan really falls apart into
needless complexity the hilarious thing
is that Henry repeatedly stresses the
need to plan for every contingency
but then fails to plan for even basic
contingencies everything has to be timed
to the second every movement every angle
every footstep there's no room for error
the most glaring hole is instead
one lure Glen out into the woods
apparently the best idea the authors
could come up with was making noise with
a walkie-talkie strapped to an amplifier
seriously that's the plan
Susan whistles into a walkie-talkie and
this noise is suspicious enough that
Glen gets his gun before going to
investigate it also needs to be stressed
hear that everything in the details of
the plan hinged on a very tight schedule
as Susan needs to be seen at the talent
show get home kill Glenn dispose of the
evidence and get back before anyone
notices that she's gone so plan for
every contingency but the whole thing
falls apart if Glen watches a movie gets
a phone call takes a shower or does
literally anything that would prevent or
delay hearing the noise that's supposed
to lure him out into the woods to his
death another great problem with the
plan is that Henry via tape has Susan
run around to a bunch of different ATMs
to withdraw a few hundred dollars in
cash at each he says that this is to
avoid suspicion and get around
withdrawal limits but hitting up a bunch
of different ATMs in a short span of
time is exactly the kind of behavior
that's going to draw suspicion also
Susan you're rich you have well over a
million dollars in investments in cash
just go to the bank and take out the
money like a normal person it's not even
that much she only takes out $1,500
which is one not enough to buy the
hardware she gets from the gun store and
to not a suspicious amount of money
that's buying crap off Kijiji money
though also last note here just because
it's hilarious I would is only slightly
thicker than the human skull this isn't
a flaw in the plan it's just a really
dumb line one that they were so proud of
that they made sure to include in the
title cards you're shooting 30 caliber
frangible bullets his his skull his
skull isn't gonna be the problem here
cuz it's better for my psychosocial
development I mean to interact with the
peer group and enormous going down I
didn't want it to be a precocious kid
who had a bunch of facts in his head it
wasn't really that roll and I felt like
to me it was a little bit more about
emotional intelligence than it was I
you for this kid that is a mind-boggling
statement that just says so much about
the way Colin Trevorrow sees the world
Henry is the least emotionally aware
person in the film he's actually a huge
prick I mean his first real scene is him
dunking on this kid Tommy for not being
grown-up enough for Henry's tastes
[Music]
dodgeball isn't even an Olympic sport
rather than being a kid who was being
unfairly forced to grow up by a
negligent absent or addicted parent
Henry has self-appointed himself to be
the adult this is tied to the movies
characterization of Susan which we'll
get to shortly but there's no indication
that things wouldn't get done without
Henry around Henry is the kind of person
who self martyr's because they see other
people as incompetent the film also
tries to play Henry two ways and can't
decide which is which Susan tells him to
spend less time focused on his
schoolwork and there's a whole half a
scene about all the awards that Henry
wins for extracurricular activities so
on one hand we're supposed to think
about Henry as the kind of Keener who
does all the bonus work and then some
but then in that first scene the Tyler
Durden jr. speech Henry is supposed to
be reading an essay that he's written
except he's clearly just improvising he
didn't do the work at all
so there's the other implication that
he's a waster the smart kid who thinks
the work is beneath him and to cap it
off he mocks his teacher we can't buy
you a gift at school because it's better
for my psychosocial development for me
to interact with the peer group and
enormous board over now this whole
moment is demonstrably false every shot
of him in class
he looks absurdly bored and he doesn't
have any friends
Henry spends his lunch playing checkers
in the cafeteria with the lunch lady a
scene where he does the whole movie
smart person shorthand of beating the
game in one move just to show that he
was in control all along which is again
a huge dick move it's also incredibly
hack on the part of the screenwriter
like this is just the worst kind of lazy
trope oh and we can't forget the scene
where Henry cop on the edge bursts in
- goddammit Janice's office and
threatens to turn in his badge goddamnit
Jin is how much longer does this have to
go on what else do you need to see Henry
also gets really judgey about Susan
playing video games he mocks the way
that she plays and polices what she does
with her free time he's he's actually
really really condescending to Susan
constantly I really want you getting
your car I like you can't afford it are
you really read it know what it says
yeah no it doesn't actually help when
you lean into it like that it was well
told I told you you don't have to work
anymore it's really great how you enable
her alcoholism violence is the worst
thing in the world Jesus mom really turn
it off no I was thinking when we get out
of home I need you to bring in the
financial files oh don't you worry I
found the second file drawer in my
captain that I also need to get a hold
of the retirement listening to me what
you need to buy a new car ready mom this
is really important no it's not
important at all keep an eye on the tech
stocks you have to watch them closer
than the other let's delete last one I'm
not doing that right what no she's not
now the middle finger is a gesture with
a high degree of plasticity you have
your classic style Detroit style the
web-shooters and of course the Logan
there is nothing wrong with her form
you're not being accurate you're just
being a dick and you deserve to get
flipped off oh and of course how can we
forget the part where Henry cooks up a
plot to murder his neighbor to me it was
a little bit more about emotional
intelligence than it was IQ
you have to ask your eleven-year-old 12
he's almost 12 how the film
characterizes Susan is for me at least
the weirdest part of the way the movie
is constructed all of the previous stuff
about the way that Henry interacts with
her there's a dissonance in that the
movie still seems to think that Henry is
always correct he's an genius as
directed by someone who doesn't think
that he's an
the byproduct of this is that every time
Henry is a judgy prick to his mom the
framing and consequences always skewed
towards Henry Jesus mom really even in
the big deathbed argument where Henry
tells Susan to focus on the finances and
Susan says it doesn't matter
this isn't ultimately framed as Henry's
failure his fear in the face of
mortality but instead as Susan's
weakness within the framework of the
story this isn't Henry in denial
it's Henry trying to tie up loose ends
because he's the adult in the
relationship mom this is really
important oh it's not important at all
keep an eye on the text ducks you have
to watch them close Henry's plans and
behavior never actually fail or fall
apart the closest it gets is when Susan
decides not to shoot Glenn but nothing
actually comes from that because Glenn
kills himself a few minutes later this
moment right here where Susan goes off
script this is where the story finally
picks up where the stakes are raised but
then it just ends and everything goes
according to Henry's plan with no
fallout whatsoever so this creates a
dynamic where the film is constantly
suggesting things about Susan that
aren't actually true if you think about
it for more than a minute from a
structural standpoint the main problem
with Susan is that she has no arc as a
character because none of her real
problems are addressed and the problem
that is addressed was never truly a
problem Susan's deal is that she's
complacent she's comfortable she's safe
she's financially secure and she's just
kind of coasting through life raising
her two kids enjoying being in a place
where nothing requires her constant
unbroken attention she has plenty of
time to bond with her kids drive them to
and from school take them to events
make them breakfast and pack their
lunches now she does have a bad case of
cool mom sweetie please Susan she's
overly codependent on Henry and she has
no real ambitions but the family is
objectively doing all right she's not
super keyed into the family finances
because she doesn't need to be that's
the luxury of being well-off regardless
of Henry's involvement this goes back to
everything we talked about with the
money subplot Susan ostensibly doesn't
know about all the money that Henry has
made on the stock market but it doesn't
seem to bother Susan at all as far as
she's concerned the family is
financially secure off whatever income
she has and nothing suggests that if it
weren't for Henry they'd be screwed I
mean presumably they survived just fine
before Henry started trading stocks
right being a cool mom is a character
flaw in the absolute sense but there's
no stakes to it in and of itself cool
mom is a surface-level problem a
behavioral problem that makes other
problems worse being a cool mom didn't
lead to Henry's rapid onset terminal
brain cancer being overlooked it's only
kind of a problem for one scene after
Henry's death where she has a very
justifiable
but temporary breakdown nothing that
goes wrong in the second half of the
movie has anything to do with the things
she was failing to do when Henry was
alive things that Henry was doing that
she the parent should have been doing
instead the thing that the movie chooses
to use as synecdoche for Susan's
negligence is that she plays video games
and has won girls night with Sheila but
none of this is ever at the cost of
anything she's not playing games instead
of getting groceries or making breakfast
she's not playing games instead of going
to work which would still be pointless
since the movie has explicitly told us
that she doesn't need to go to work in
the first place she's not drinking
instead of helping with homework or
getting drunk in the middle of the day
or inviting Sheila over six nights a
week she's just playing video games
sometimes yeah the movie is super
judgmental about Sue
not spending literally 100 percent of
her time focused on her kids so as a
character arc she kind of learns at the
very end to see her genius dead kid as
the kid he was and not the small adult
he acted like but he's already dead so
it's not like that changes anything
aside from that she's just kind of
complacent her subplot about wanting to
be a picture book author is well it's
it's a disingenuous to even call it a
subplot it's not Susan's ambition so
much as it's the one of her three
hobbies that the movie approves of and
your father's lucky to have you two
stepfather
all right this one is the heavy one
Cristina's involvement in the film is a
textbook example of a prop character you
could replace her with just about
anything and the plot would still work
she could be a sack of jewels that Glen
has stolen and very little would
actually change the plot to kill Glen is
supposedly motivated by the desire to
save Christina from abuse but Christina
isn't involved in it at all
her agency in all of this is utterly
absent and this is why it's really just
a plot to kill Glen not a plot to save
Christina the whole story started from
the idea of a genius kid planning the
perfect crime and the dudes who made it
were so busy high-fiving each other for
their wit that they didn't bother to ask
if a story about an 11 year old being
raped by her stepdad was the best
vehicle for that the tonal tightrope
walk of this movie is a deeply
challenging one and it's one of the
reasons I wanted to be involved it and
it breaks I think pretty much all the
rules of screenwriting like if you look
at the books that they give you in
college at least the first three
chapters just rip them out in this one
of the things that was a challenge was
managing the tone oh Jesus they think
they nailed it anyway Christina only has
a half-dozen lines in the entire movie
and no one bothers to even try and
empower her only taking the time to make
a few anonymous phone calls before
giving up entirely yet we're expected to
believe that she's so close with the
carpenter family that she has fancy
personal handshakes with Susan and slots
effort
into the whole Henry left-behind night
butterfly from a storytelling standpoint
there's a whole host of problems with
how this entire plot unfolds we the
audience first get the inkling that
something's wrong when Henry notices
that Christina is sad on the playground
that night by happenstance Henry is
looking out his bedroom window when he
sees presumably Christina being abused
by Glenn now from our perspective this
is the inciting moment Henry has
discovered a crime and is now going to
start trying to correct it the next
morning he tries lightly to prod
Christina in the car and then in class
when she isn't interested in a donut he
gets up storms into the principal's
office and damages how much longer does
this have to go on this is complete
whiplash we're 20 minutes into the movie
and all of a sudden this isn't something
new this is now an ongoing thing that
he's tried to report before he's dumping
all this new information that
contradicts what we were just told
everything about the framing music and
acting in the previous scenes indicates
that this is new not some long-running
thing that Henry has been dealing with
in the first scene with all the key
players nothing about this plot is
indicated beyond the fact that the kids
don't particularly like Glenn also in
one of the weirdest creative decisions
even though Henry says she's been coming
to school with bruises the hacks that
went with this visual shorthand decided
that they weren't going to go with a
visible bruise it's weird
why wouldn't you show us that it's it's
the easiest thing to show and then
goddamnit Janis says she needs concrete
proof but bruises weren't enough I guess
all of this repeats again at the end
when Susan makes all of the same claims
that she apparently has all this
information stashed away but we've never
seen any of it which is just asinine in
a story that's literally focused on
planning and details we have the process
Henry used to partially Forge custody
papers but zilch about gathering actual
evidence against Glenn
Henry documented all of it the movie has
this really weird aversion to making any
of the characters actually flawed or
negligent in some way if the filmmakers
gave Christina visible bruises that they
show us while suddenly every character
who can see those bruises including
Susan teachers and goddamit Janice are
accountable their failure to react or
willingness to overlook that information
is damning and makes them complicit in
Glens abuse so the movie goes to weird
lengths to give everyone an out no one
makes actual awful mistakes they just
make implied mistakes I mean that's why
they're even doing this flimsy due
diligence in the first place it's all
just shoddy convenience so that Henry
can be blameless when he decides to plan
to kill Glenn make it look like there
was no other option instead of implying
that maybe Henry was actually just a
little too eager to kill mr. cyclamen
next door easily one of the strangest
elements of the movie is the weird
mangled Jesus metaphor first of all the
movie is called The Book of Henry an
aesthetic call to the naming of biblical
books the book of Matthew the book of
John The Book of Jeremiah job as her
Ezekiel Mark Luke Esther Ruth Malachi
second Henry's death is an aesthetic
call to pietà sculpture the thinking
man's Jesus imagery for when a
crucifixion pose would be too crass
third Henry's number-one disciple the
one who first takes his words and
convinces others of their importance is
named Peter forth the family name is
carpenter which is only about one step
down from when lost had a metaphysical
guide named Christian Shepherd fifth at
the very end susan reads her new story
about how a flower dies and fertilizes a
garden with its body which is just a
muddy repaint of the christian belief
that jesus died to exalt mankind but is
also clearly intended as a metaphor for
henry who died but made things better in
the process okay so the movie thinks
that it's message is about apathy
the worst thing in the world what is
then apathy so the takeaway here is that
the death of Henry is what taught Susan
to be less apathetic and to reach out
and help others that she went from being
unwilling to intervene in the grocery
store to willing to kill blen and forge
documents in order to save Christina but
she didn't kill Glenn and in fact once
she learns about Christina's situation
especially once she sees it for herself
she's anything but apathetic sure the
things that she tries are largely
ineffective and she quickly latches on
to the murder plot but she doesn't need
any persuading to care even in the
grocery store the problem is an apathy
it's feeling powerless she's worried
that if she intervenes it will make
things worse
this is not the moral failing she
actually overcomes it's never even
implied that killing Glen might have
unforeseen negative outcomes oh and if
you want an actual example of a bad day
who sex machina ending it would be when
principal goddammit Janice decides
completely independently of the actions
of any of the characters to finally do
her job in a way that neatly resolves
all conflicts while absolving the
central characters for any of their
actions Susan gets away with attempted
murder because Glenn kills himself
before he can tell anyone what she did
there's so so much more that we could
talk about but to wrap this up I want to
talk about one scene in particular my
favorite scene in the whole movie for
how utterly absurd it is at every level
of conception for Peters act in the
talent show
he pushes out a large chest and says
that he will make his brother Henry
reappear now there's a critical detail
from earlier that needs to be mentioned
after Henry's death there's no funeral
scene
not even in montage this is important
because this moment with Peter on stage
is supposed to create some uncertainty
did Henry genius child in Jesus metaphor
in fact faked his own death and will now
pop out
to the delight of all who knows so Peter
opens the chest kicks it and it starts
spraying fake snow out over the audience
just just everywhere it's just
everywhere then everyone gets up
standing ovations Peter and Susan hug so
this scene this scene all right what's
going on here
what they're trying to do this is
obviously a callback to the
mountain-climbing nonsense from earlier
which no one in the crowd would be
familiar with so this is literally just
a chest that spits out face snow
metaphorically this is the book of
Henry's version of the baptism of fire
inside it's mangled Jesus metaphor Peter
chief apostle has preached to the crowd
the whimsy of Henry and his Spirit has
descended upon them but you know what
else it means visually it means that
Peter has promised the crowd that his
brother Henry would be physically right
here among them and then he sprays them
with a dry white powder the visual
implication however unintended is that
Peter scatters Henry's ashes over the
crowd standing ovations
[Music]
you